Jake you play the son of here this is
very complicated you play these son and
Trippi also the son of your dad Gary
Busey's Gary Busey's predator to
character yeah it's crazy that's I'm
just thinking about it I don't know
where there's precedent for that it's a
very yeah well you know that I'll tell
you I spent 25 years trying to develop a
career where I could I'd stood on my own
two feet I'm proud of the work that I
did didn't ask for help or favors from
my dad and I'm you know trying to seek
that individuality and then Shane calls
me and says would you like to be a part
of this movie I got this idea maybe you
play your dad's characters kid and and
it all just hit ya it's perfect timing
yeah it's perfect to bring it all around
bring it home and so it was it's a great
honor and I'm like super thankful to
have been a part of it we have a picture
here we have a picture of we have a
picture of your dad from predator 2 and
I'm just curious serious that's him
between takes just yeah yeah that's his
day off
that's Thanksgiving at the Busey home
what I'm curious about is do you
remember as a kid going to visit him on
the set of predator 2 I do I was in high
school and I went to visit I had lunch
there one day and I was I was you know
watching the the scene and he's it's the
scene where he and Danny Glover get into
a scuffle at the I guess at the Town
Hall or something like that the court
courtroom so my dad comes walking up and
he goes check out my suit look at this
this is what people are gonna be
dressing like in 1997 an eerie glimpse
into the future
you